[Musica]
ergonomia parleremo di un errore
ortografico o meglio di un neologismo di
una parola che io utilizzo spesso
proprio per cercare di semplificare
tematiche molto complesse economia
finanza finanza sostenibile
sostenibilità non è facile della domanda
che più spesso ricevono gli ultimi anni
è proprio questa ma paolo la
sostenibilità è una moda io rispondo
sempre nello stesso modo
no la sostenibilità non è una moda è un
modo diverso di vedere le cose eh sì
perché è importantissimo ragionarci le
prospettive cambiare prospettiva siamo
di fronte probabilmente ad una parola
importantissima sostenibilità ne
parliamo di sviluppo sostenibili a
quanto meno dal 1992 il problema è che
oggi siamo
all'interno di una giungla di parole due
edifici anche districarsi nel 1992 ci
avevano spiegato che lo sviluppo
sostenibile a mettere in relazione le
persone con l'ambiente e l'attività
dell'essere umano sul pianeta stava
diventando insostenibile era il 1992 la
conferenza delle nazioni unite di rio de
janeiro
ecco da allora ad oggi tantissime parole
tanti concetti in finanza ad esempio i
criteri e sg i principi di
responsabilità dell'investimento gli
essere ai e tutte quelle parole in
inglese che utilizziamo per parlare di
economia green economy circolare co nomi
engagement incluse un'esclusione
frugal economy ecco chi più ne ha più ne
metta e poi arriviamo fino veramente a
parole più importanti più di peso anche
più di cuore ad esempio sulla stagi sa
che è quella sensazione di sgomento che
ci prende di fronte alle calamità
naturali che continuiamo a vedere sempre
più frequentemente proprio davanti ai
nostri occhi il pianeta terra è uno e
non è infinito oggi parliamo di infinito
futuro ecco nell'economia il concetto è
proprio questo cercare di riavvicinare i
temi economici ai temi di sostenibilità
in maniera importante preponderante
anche perché se allontaniamo un po lo
sguardo da tutto questo e guardiamo al
pianeta magari da questa fotografia
quella della sonda voyager 1 che nel
1990 fotografava la terra ma da oltre
l'orbita di nettuno ci rendiamo conto di
quanto questo pianeta che veniva
chiamato il the babe ludot cioè questo
piccolo pallino pallido azzurro sia
fragile ma ricordiamocelo è l'unico
pianeta nella galassia che ci permette
di avere la vita dell'essere umano
ecco da questo punto di vista allora
parlare di economia
senza includere le tematiche di
sostenibilità non ha più senso oggi e
quindi in semplificazione mettere in
relazione l'intersezione tra ambiente
società ed economia governi imprese
finanza il denaro che diventa non più il
fine delle cose ma il mezzo con cui fare
le cose come fare le cose e perché si
fanno le cose la politica di scopo
diventa fondamentale e quindi quelle tre
ii iii e sg environmental social
governance stanno a significare che se
noi rispettiamo l'ambiente
rispettiamo le persone e i territori e
rispettiamo le regole di condotta
avremo sicuramente un'impresa è un modo
di vivere migliore e più sano per tutti
per la generazione presente ma
soprattutto per quelle future
e il denaro che sta arrivando è enorme e
sg ed economia quindi come si diceva
diventano una parola sola ergonomia
ecco l'economia oggi ha un significato
anche importante perché il regolatore ci
sta aiutando la comunità europea ha
legiferato la tassonomia ci permetterà
di parlare tutti lo stesso linguaggio e
futuro economico sociale di impresa
finanziario e avremo anche modo di avere
i dati finanziari delle società ma non
solo finanziari la nuova legge la n fdr
quindi la non fa nasce al discorso in
regulation obbliga le aziende quotate
più grandi a pubblicare non solo
bilancio finanziario lo stato
patrimoniale come fanno le cose quindi
quanti soldi si fanno gli utili ma
devono anche soprattutto pubblicare il
cosiddetto bilancio non finanziarie
quindi la matrice di materialità dove
noi possiamo vedere con dei numeri gli
impatti che rispetto a cosa ha proprio
quei criteri di sg che ci permettono di
valorizzare il modello di business
dell'azienda nel lungo termine quindi il
loro valore intrinseco per tutti noi
ecco oggi la finanza ha un ruolo
fondamentale quello che mi piace
identificare questa metafora del
giardiniere la finanza deve aiutare il
denaro l'acqua ad arrivare alle piante
più rigenerative di un giardino che
accolga 10 miliardi di persone nel 2050
sono due miliardi e mezzo in più di
persone rispetto ad oggi
sono tantissime persone più e per
poterlo ospitare in questo pianeta
indubbiamente ne ho bisogno di
rimodellare il come facciamo le cose
stanno arrivando 10 mila miliardi di
dollari attraverso le politiche
monetarie dei tanti paesi e saper infra
starci un flan di biden gli stati uniti
il piano quinquennale della cina in next
generation europeo sono 2mila miliardi
di euro messi a disposizione con una
politica di scopo che è nel nome di
questo piano lo chiamiamo tutti i
ricoveri fans sbagliando il ricovero i
fan è la facilità e lo strumento
richiamare il debito per finanziare cosa
i progetti per ristrutturare il futuro
di chi della next generation
un bellissimo 9 per favore non
chiamatelo più recovery fan non dobbiamo
tornare a rifare le cose di prima male
come prima ma dobbiamo evolvere dobbiamo
andare avanti e allora ogni singolo
stato anche una comunità europea di
questi duemila miliardi avrà tantissime
disponibilità e con questa disponibilità
dobbiamo sicuramente evolvere evolvere
in maniera sostenibile
guarda che l'economia dell'italia con un
pnr r quindi piano nazionale di ripresa
resilienza avrà a disposizione 191.5
miliardi di euro nei prossimi sei anni
da suddividere sei missioni che però
sono proprio ergonomiche c'è la tutela
dell'ambiente la circolarità la
transizione ecologica il ministero di
cingolani nuovo che abbiamo appena
istituito ci sono l'inclusione lo
sviluppo delle politiche ad esempio
sanitarie quindi la parte sociale la
parte della coesione sociale e poi la
digitalizzazione e la competitività
dobbiamo rimanere competitivi perché
nessuno parla di recessione e
sostenibile parliamo tutti di sviluppo
sostenibile e allora nel fare questo per
l'attenzione che c'è anche un urgenza
che è sicuramente quella climatica la
più evidente di tutte lo sapete che
l'effetto serra è praticamente un
sacchetto di plastica intorno al nostro
pianeta noi lo stiamo riempendo di
biossido di carbonio e questo fa sì che
la temperatura media terrestre si stia
alzando dall'invenzione della macchina a
vapore ad oggi un grado punto uno guarda
che tantissimo le traiettorie di
sviluppo della temperatura con il nostro
modello di vita attuale ci porteranno a
quasi 4 gradi centigradi
a fine secolo e le condizioni di vita
saranno insostenibili
allora non a caso la conferenza delle
parti
ha siglato un limite di cosiddetto
carbon budget e non a caso stiamo tutti
cercando di parlare di fare industria
impresa di vivere in modo diverso e di
emettere meno di ossido di carbonio
abbiamo bisogno di fare transizione
mitigazione è importantissimo perché
sennò le temperature terrestri diventano
veramente non accoglienti e guardate che
in italia dove abbiamo inventato il
termometro per cui abbiamo le
rilevazioni della temperatura reali dal
1800 ad oggi la temperatura di italiana
è già salita di circa 3 gradi centigradi
non a caso difatti abbiamo avuto due mia
18 l'anno più caldo d'italia di sempre
alla nostra storia e guarda che gli
scorsi sette anni sono stati sette anni
più caldi del pianeta da sempre ma noi
oggi parliamo di tropicalizzazione della
tenuta padana vediamo quello che succede
a venezia ma non solo ormai i danni
degli uragani li stiamo vedendo nelle
nostre isole si parla ormai di mediche
in mediterranean jurak e stiamo parlando
il ciclone nel nostro mar mediterraneo
stiamo osservando dei cambiamenti
climatici che indubbiamente ci spingono
a parlare di transizione energetica la
transizione ecologica più importante è
proprio quella energetica
consumeremo sempre più energia siamo
sempre più persone oggi già consumiamo
606 exajoule di energia all'anno che è
un numero gigantesco è un uomo genetico
di energia pensare che un singolo joule
e alzare un'arancia di 100 grammi di un
metro ecco tutta questa produzione come
viene fatta viene fatta questa energia
attraverso tre elementi climalteranti
carbone petrolio e gas naturale
all'ottanta per cento ed ecco da qui le
emissioni di biossido di carbonio
nell'atmosfera con quello che facciamo
né come generiamo all'energia allora è
ovvio che dal secolo il carbone siamo
passati al secolo del petrolio ma questo
deve essere per forza di cose il secolo
delle energie rinnovabili
allora se faremo sì che questo avvenga
abbiamo bisogno di tantissima
innovazione e di idee di nuovi modelli
di business
dobbiamo modificare proprio tutto dalla
generazione proprio dell'energia e
quindi abbiamo bisogno di innovazioni
non tanto per andare su marte ma
possibilmente per evitare di doverci
andare
un'impresa che oggi investe nel capitale
umano
pensa ad includere nessun modello di
business
il rispetto per l'ambiente
e adotta buone regole di condotta è per
definizione una buona azienda è
un'azienda che ci farà bene farà bene e
ci aiuterà in questa transizione in una
transizione che ci porterà dal vecchio
modello di economia lineare che
conosciamo prendo uso smaltisco poi
vediamo come smaltisco ad un modello più
circolare che includa innovazione
ricerca sviluppo abbiamo delle realtà
italiane meravigliose abbiamo dei leader
di produzione di energia rinnovabile
abbiamo delle aziende che riescono a
recuperare il nylon dalle reti della
pesca abbandonate negli oceani piuttosto
che delle vecchie e moquette e degli
hotel e ricreano del materiale per poter
fare ad esempio di costumi da bagno
bellissimi abbiamo azienda che prendono
700mila tonnellate di rifiuti di arance
nel pastazzo d'agrumi sicilia e la
trasformano un tessuto tessile per fare
delle nuove cravatte bellissime ecco la
rigenerazione della residenza il riciclo
delle cose la longevità abbiamo un
camion di vestiti al secondo che finisce
in discarica
ecco questo non è più sostenibile
il tema dell'infinito futuro è proprio
questo se vogliamo pensare al futuro dei
nostri figli dei nostri tempo di noi
dobbiamo iniziare oggi a modificare gli
atteggiamenti di una collettività che
sta consumando troppo un pianeta che le
risorse non ne ha infinite allora in
un'economia circolare e non più lineare
indubbiamente gli obiettivi sono
importantissimi e chi ce li dà gli
obiettivi ci risiamo auto dati nel 2015
così come alla coop 21 di parigi abbiamo
dato il limite delle emissioni di carbon
fossile nell'atmosfera
l'onu ci ha regalato un'altra cosa gli
obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile 17 169
target e guardate che sono tutte cose
molto intelligenti non ridurre la fame
nel mondo aumentare l'educazione
fare le cose ma farlo in maniera
migliore senza inquinare senza emettere
biossido di carbonio
se volete li possiamo sintetizzare in
due grandi sfere e sono due sfere di
bisogni importantissime che mi
permettono di parlarvi del concetto di
capitalismo responsabile da una parte
abbiamo tutti gli obiettivi legati al
miglioramento della coesione sociale
le persone
il come viviamo dall'altra abbiamo la
transizione energetica il come generiamo
l'energia di cui abbiamo bisogno per
vivere
allora se noi pensiamo a questo c'è
stata un economista europea inglese
bravissima kate report che ci ha scritto
proprio un modo secondo me dei libri più
interessanti di economia moderna de
donnas economy la teoria economica della
ciambella non so se lo avete mai letto
ecco è interessantissimo perché lei usa
proprio questa forma no questa forma
della cennata pericolosa ci guardate che
proprio una questione di equilibri tra
carenze ed eccessi proprio relativi al
come facciamo le cose e al perché le
facciamo quindi mettiamoci dei limiti in
quello che facciamo cerchiamo di non
dare carenze ad esempio i bisogni
primari l'acqua il cibo la salute la
disuguaglianza l'accesso alla sanità e
senza andare in carenza libro cerchiamo
anche di non fare di eccedere in quello
che facciamo di superare i limiti
ecologici la forestazione
l'inquinamento la biodiversità
l'acidificazione degli oceani
perché se continuiamo a fare questo e ad
eccedere questi limiti non rimarremo nel
buono in questo capitalismo responsabile
che è rappresentato da questa ciambella
il capitalismo responsabile ripeto non
ci dice di frenare di non fare più le
cose ci dice però di pensare al mondo
non più solo basato sulla crescita su
consumismo ma prendete la parola
crescità è trasformata line prosperità
vedete come state mettendo insieme è
stata includendo gli aspetti di coesione
sociale con quelli di transizione
ecologica
ecco fare questo vuol dire magari un
domani anche guardare i cosiddetti pia
in maniera diversa cosa sa cosa sono i
tipi ai no questi standard che dobbiamo
analizzare per capire se un'azienda è
buona o no ecco io mi occupo di questo
faccio finanziata da tutta la mia
carriera e allora un business è buono se
riesce effettivamente
magari non solo ad avere un buon pil
prodotto interno lordo ma pensate quanto
sarebbe meglio giudicare un'azienda
nella sua prosperità interna lorda
aggiungendo anche la felicità nel
modello di quello che viene fatto allora
quando io ho iniziato a lavorare in
finanza
diciamo la fine degli anni 80 un film
famosissimo ve lo ricordate tutti a wall
street io ho iniziato a lavorare in
borsa italiana nel 98 qui facevo trader
azionario compravo non devo tutto il
giorno estremamente non sostenibile
praticamente non dormivo mai
ecco però la mia aspirazione che mi
arrivava dalle persone che mi avevano
dato dei messaggi erano quelle proprio
anche di quel film di bill e ricordate
le barattelle di gordon gekko greed is
good grace fire l'avidità è buona la
vita è bene
ecco secondo me tutto sta cambiando e
sta cambiando la velocità della luce io
dico per fortuna anche perché basta
cambiare una singola lettera e da greed
is good redesign si può passare a green
is good ridens fai il verde e il fatto
di fare un ragionamento sulle
innovazioni più inclusivo di quello che
potrà essere una produzione ad esempio
agroalimentare che vada a eliminare il
problema dei rifiuti voi sapete che
produciamo nel mondo cibo e di questo
cibo nella catena di produzione ne
perdiamo il 16 per cento totale e lo
perdiamo soprattutto nei nostri
frigoriferi in europa 180 kg pro capite
viene disperso e diventa rifiuto
alimentare pro capite è una cifra enorme
allora possiamo magari pensare a culture
nuove come quella idroponica che non
hanno nemmeno bisogno del suolo per
poter generare magari cibo in futuro
guarda che il vertical farming è una di
quelle tantissime innovazioni che ci
stanno permettendo oggi di fare una
nuova economia di fare nuovi modelli di
business di portare ad avere un
significato nuovo e gli stessi prodotti
di prima ma fatti in maniera diversa
ecco io ho per rispondere in conclusione
e soprattutto la domanda che mi fanno
tantissimo i miei nipoti miei nipotini
lo zio ma quale sarà il lavoro più bello
più importante per il domani e io a loro
vorrei rispondere così non lo so se fare
gli influencer il digital architett di
instagram sarà la cosa più interessante
quella magari non si guadagnerà di più
ma se pensate un domani di lavorare in
un'azienda che abbia sposato i principi
dell'ergonomia che vi sto raccontando
sicuramente avrete davanti a voi una
grandissima opportunità quella di fare
un lavoro che vi piacerà che vi
realizzerà nella vita ma soprattutto
farà anche del bene agli altri
ecco con questo augurerò ai miei nipoti
a tutti voi un domani di magari
diventare dei chief vision officer ossia
delle persone che porteranno visione
anche perché del futuro ricordatevelo
sempre non è importante prevederlo ma
renderlo possibile
[Applauso]
[Musica]